i g my name it's p welcome back to Eve
uh I don't know which part it is I don't
really care I can't stop playing this
this game is awesome e are you ready yes
I'm ready let's get going oh hold on a
moment you forgot my dead baby seal
there we go oh it's my
[Music]
jacket ah [__] the creepiness begins I
hate you I hate all of you not not not
you I not the paintings you knew that ah
[__] ah [__] it's knocking on the door
it's
[Music]
locked ah I don't like
this okay
what ah ah H H C down there come on it's
fine it's fine it's fine it's
F come on green
button I'm
sorry what did I do oh oh I'm AF free
I'm free I'm free cuz I'm free why did I
go in there no more explor oh I hate
those [__]
mannequins oh [__] milk puzzle have you
heard no I haven't well I name implies
it's a puzzle where all
the of
course very smart people can finish them
in no time at all but to be honest
they're not exciting since they don't
make don't even make yeah you're right
it feels more worth it yeah I think so
true that probably means I'm not that
smart all right it's
moving all right it's beautiful
beautiful oh not
again uh I love this picture it's so
cute uh
okay sheez this statue is blocking the
way he's so awesome Gary
Oaks what is
this what did I
do all
right
well that makes no [__]
sense uh I'm not getting ideas let's
look around somewhere all
right something put in it that's what
she said well I don't know what the [__]
we're going to put in it uh [__] do you
have something on
you oh my god oh wait here's something
we look here there's some text on the
wall uh Guan as exped
a big fish painting right did you see it
e oh yeah it was this one word no I
don't remember
it oh it was
abys
yes yes that was it abis of the de did
you read that yeah I
did why why why every remember
this
what
oh that was
it
okay
genius like playing loves me loves me
not all right separation what an
outputting
painting what ah [__] it's too dark to
see e uh I'm here I'm not troll face
that's good to hear stay all
[Applause]
right uh don't
kill
huh uh a
[Music]
[__] yep it's not good for anyone as
hell what Gary closed the book
well done Gary I thought it was
something porn ah [__] it they women
here well this got to be something can
we go
now what the rose is covering the text
so I can't see what it says oh note this
to all visitor there is a strict ban of
fire starting in the gallery we resist
that you
place
okay
yeah that is creepy why would they do
that ah someone lost their shoes stupid
[__] oh they went in here I see this
door ow what she doing oh are you
okay wait could you be the oh
okay
what I'm I'm Gary and this girl is e
we were in the art gallery but then
someone found herself l in the now we're
both trying to find a way out presumably
you're doing the
same I was uh I was looking to see if
there was anyone else there so I wanted
so I well I knew it well would you like
to come B then huh it's dangerous to go
alone take this there's a lot of strange
creatures around you will come with us I
think all right yeah I come and then is
decided what's your name Mary nice to
meet you yeah Eve just doesn't talk at
all yeah all right now that we have more
company we can all right yay that is so
gay that is so gay force of aquarel I
like that they don't follow you all
right at least
uh yeah say seeing as if e and I both
have roses Mary do you have a rose as
well yeah I will
yell
[Music]
but also like pink and blue learn to
listen would you all right she's super
annoying May is better which one could
it be
what ah come
on well is that [__] in our party now
yep all right flowers of jealousy
cool hey the bunny
B oh look at this [__] yeah red eye the
love of this painting this
room I think it's cute what about this
is cute I just uh not
sure well all right then let's try to
get out of this creepy Place quick I
feel I'm being watched It's unsettling
uh apparently I guess all the things
that I talk about is
changes um what it [__] jumped it
killed himself for a key thank you bunny
for killing yourself your sacrifice will
not be in
vain uh apparently you get a different
ending and oh [__] oh
[__] oh
[__] ah
[__] oh no no no
ah that was
scary H what is
this
ah okay yes of course it does stop being
silly come on well I wonder if you'll be
okay well I'm fine I'd rather not split
up I suppose you're right there isn't
much else okay [__] Gary I [__] why am I
with this [__] girl ah I'm sorry I
got to go son of a [__] all right let's
go in here ah there's boxes and all kind
of stuff ah shooker let's check the room
first [__] thinks she knows
everything
uh okay she finds something a
knife let's try
it
[Music]
I hate her why did she say that to me
one
uh-oh that scared me
[Music]
uh okay what about this
one oh no
oh we got to move
on stop stop stop stop stop stop you
creeps me the [__] out of me what the
hell is
that ah that is
creepy
ah
okay oh okay cool we'll be together you
and me are not our friends
okay okay what is this
well we didn't want to do it Gary what
are you
[Music]
doing oh we can't hear you because we
kept walking I shouldn't have let them
alone what do I
[Music]
do oh I'm playing as Gary oh okay
ah red eyes this is defin that cute def
they all have [__] red eyes all right
what about you you're back to life
now that is just creepy as
hell oh all
right I guess I go in
[Music]
there a [__] what is
this oh oh switch switcher
R Who
[Music]
[__]
you don't kill
me all right it's a p it opens the
bridge
cool cool all right your turn e your
turn save this in
case uh stare
intensely ah [__] I think we need those
eyes to close so let's try and do that
first
ah
[__]
[Music]
what a
[__] okay
uh uh what is that can we go in here of
course is log there's no exit
[__]
stop what does that
do all right well I guess we got to
cross
[Music]
anyway
yeah boink something is moving inside oh
[__] okay fine
whoa a I'm an
idiot we need this little
thing not sure if I was supposed to do
that oh it's little Santa Claus hey how
you doing what what is Gary your dad no
so your dad is someone else I
see not when she's mad
ha I she gets mad at you well you want
to see your parents again soon right uh
all right fine stupid
questions stupid moms being mad and [__]
all right here we
go what what was that flickering
fisherman it's locked should we continue
as Gary here oh okay we got this now I
don't
know oh it fell down for him
cool
yay thanks da thanks M thank M oh [__] I
got to end this episode [__] time
flies by fast when we play this game I'm
not going to lie this disturbing doll
that is fantastic hello there Gary you
don't like being alone take me with
you
[Music]
nope all right like video If you enjoyed
subscribe I'll see next episode of
whatever I
[Music]
make I know Fu out there hey how you
doing hey how you doing hey how
you you that was so loud ah stop
shooting a